Allan Wake is a bizarre game with a
distinct gameplay formula and story that
I find it hard to put down I loved Alan
Wake when I played it years ago but
today I wanted to see if those memories
still held true so in honor of Alan Wake
2 releasing in just a couple weeks we're
going to be revisiting the story of Alan
Wake I will not only be telling you what
happened in the story so you're caught
up to speed but I'll also be critiquing
it along the way this video will be
covering the base game it's 2dlc
episodes the spin-off American Nightmare
and then a brief discussion about
remedy's other game control as alen wi
does make a brief appearance there as
well without further Ado though like the
video if you enjoy and subscribe for
more content like this and as always
let's get
started Allan Wake starts with the
titular character Allan Wake arriving by
boat in a small town called bright Falls
Allen's a world famous writer most well
known for his crime detective series
Alex Casey which fils the New York City
detective through his various trials and
tribulations his last book called the
sudden stop would be his sixth and final
book in the series which ends with Alex
Casey's death he'd always wanted to move
on from Casey in his story and figured
that now was the time his next book
would have been called departure a new
story with a new protagonist but he
hasn't written anything yet it's been 2
years since his last publication and he
hasn't even written the title page Allen
is suffering from severe writers block
so he and his wife decided to take a
vacation at bright Falls a small remote
Town far away from the eyes of the
public so we can focus on relaxation
with the hope that by the end he'll feel
rejuvenated and ready to start his next
best seller ironically one of the game's
best aspects is its characterization
just as Al wi was skilled enough to
create a lovable character with
personality and flaws so to his remedy
with Allen alen Wick comes off as a nice
guy but one who's also a [__] he
tends to lose his temper quite fast and
is less than pleased when he finds out
that the server at the diner just so
happens to be one of his biggest fans
the town itself is also just as
impressive as it's that typical any Town
USA location where everyone knows
everyone and the population is likely
less than a thousand or cell it also
lays into that Trope by having his
arrival be right around the time of
their annual deer Fest which is a yearly
parade the town has and it's one of
those things that only this town would
care about due to the aforementioned
server though his stay in bright Falls
is not going to be as low-key as he
thought he also happened to make friends
with the local radio host of the town
and within about 15 minutes pretty much
everyone knows that he's visiting the
town for the time being unfortunately
being spotted is the least of his
worries as when he visits the diner and
asks for Carl Stucky the man who's
supposed to give him the key to his
place he finds a Woman in a Black Dress
similar to the one you'd wear at a
funeral she ends up giving him the key
instead and both he and his wife Alice
leave to visit the home but not before
Carl slucky rushes out of the diner
hoping to give the couple their key so
if he had the key the whole time then
who's the woman well we'll find out very
shortly as the visit didn't go is
expected Alice who puts up with a lot
more of alen wake [__] than I'd be able
to wants to surprise him with a gift she
got which is a typewriter she figured
that a change in scenery and design
would be enough to get those creative
juices flowing again but Allan argues
with her saying that he came here to
relax not work causing him to storm off
and get some air right after this the
lights in the home go out which freaks
Alice due to her fear of the dark Alan
then rushes to her location before she's
somehow dragged into the water below
like any normal human Allan attempts to
rescue his wife before he wakes up in a
car crash alongside the crash is not
only a talking bright light that is
guiding him away from the darkness
residents of the Town who are dead set
on killing him but also the title page
of a book he is the author of called
departure the same book he planned on
writing after this vacation but
apparently he already wrote welcome to
Alan Wake it should go without saying
but Alan Wake has such a strong opening
it's filled with so much mystery that
it's practically begging to be uncovered
it also does a great job of establishing
relationships and character
personalities alongside those Mysteries
you can tell that Alice and Allen both
love each other but the relationship is
a bit Rocky Allan got thrown into
Celebrity Status due to his books and
that came with all the positives and
negatives that that entails he is
successful wealthy and has a happy
marriage but he's also very
short-tempered as he not only yells at
his wife over minor problems but he also
punched someone from the paparazzi for
getting in his face underneath all that
though is someone who cares about his
family and his friends it's just buried
under mountains of stress and this
constant ruers block isn't making things
any better Ellen's ruers block is also a
lot more meta than it may seem as his
condition is all too familiar to not
only remedy but to me as well remedy
entertainment like Allan struggled for
years deciding how they wanted to craft
their story you might recognize remedy
as the creators behind max pain and at
the time outside of one game called
Death rally in the 9s that was their
only intellectual property similar to
Allan remedy had to cut ties at max pay
after their second game apogee saw Ware
who was responsible for publishing the
original game was also responsible for
publishing the sequel and was in talks
with take to interactive about bringing
the game to consoles not only did take
to agree but they would also later buy
the IP from Ry and give it to Rockstar
who would then create max pain 3 Alan
Wake killed off Alex Casey and didn't
know what to do from there and remedy
had to say goodbye to their beloved
franchise both had to move on but didn't
know where to start for years alen Wick
was drafted up to be a totally different
experience the story elements and
inspiration seem to been consistent from
beginning to end but remedy originally
planned to make the game open world
allowing the player to move freely about
the town they also wanted to introduce
survival mechanics into the gameplay
Loop by having the player scavenge for
supplies during the day while they
defending themselves against the hordes
at night none of this came to fruition
though as they struggled to make it work
for 3 years they stuck with this idea
only to stop and force themselves to do
something different they literally took
the various leads on the project and put
them in a room together with the
intention of locking down a gameplay
formul that would work well with the
rest of the game each of these entities
was stuck in a constant Loop of strength
failure and self-doubt not sure if they
would succeed well seeing as we're
talking about it today it's clear remedy
was successful in creating their vision
for the game as it not only has a host
of additional content like the dlc's and
the spin-off title American nightmare
but it finally got its sequel less
dramatic than all of this is my
connection to wake if you have
notifications for the channel turned on
which you should by the way you'll
recall that I mentioned recently how I
felt burnt out after a talk of plasmus 2
it had nothing to do with the game as I
really enjoyed it but I just think it
was the timing again against my better
judgment I tend to prioritize this
channel over my own health now I'm not
destroying myself so don't worry about
that but it has been a while since I've
given myself a proper break it is both a
blessing and a curse that I can set my
own hours when making YouTube videos if
I want to work on a video for a couple
of hours a day then I can do that but if
I want to spend every waking moment of
my life working on it then I can do that
as well I think the last time I
genuinely had a break outside of a
couple hours a day where I relax and
play some other games was the late
August since then there hasn't been a
single day where I'm not at least making
some kind of progress on a video whether
that be something I plan to release in a
week or in a few months it's stressful
and stupid but that's the issue no one
is telling me to work this way yet here
I am conforming to the standards I set
for myself while I still haven't taken
that official break and likely won't
until the end of October after Alan Wake
2 is out and even then I still might not
given that I'm thinking about making
another video like this on remedy other
games for the time being alen wake has
been my light in the darkness videos
like these allow me to be more
expressive with my writing and my
opinions and while that's nothing new
Allan Wake felt different like all the
creative juices I lost had finally come
back to me it also helps that the game
itself is filled with enough complexity
and skill for writing that I can talk
about it forever and the intro is just
the tip of the iceberg here circling
back to that comment about the gameplay
though the next rational question would
be if the open world didn't work what
did they create instead and that's
shockingly harder to explain than I
thought Alan Wake is equal parts
survival horror and action yet it feels
like neither of them at the same time I
describe it as the game having elements
of each but not fully committing to
either Allen wake is an action game but
unlike some other titles like Uncharted
a Red Dead Redemption where the game
play is more fast-paced and intense
Allen wake is slower more methodical you
want to take your time with each
encounter as you only have a limited
amount of ammo at any given time this
Falls more in line with survival horror
but it doesn't fully dive into that
realm either due to its other mechanics
most games of the genre like Resident
Evil have resource and inventory
management built into the game playay
Alan Wake has no standard inventory with
the only real choices being whether you
want a shotgun or a hunting rifle as you
can only carry one at a time the game
does have that two type system that
Resident Evil has but instead of it
being ammo and health pickups it's ammo
and batteries Allen regenerates health
over time so Health items like syringes
herbs or health packs are unnecessary
instead batteries are used in its place
due to how the gameplay works the
enemies we Face are called taken
individuals used by the dark presence
and entity I'll talk about later who are
little more than THS hell bent on
killing Allen to defeat them you must
first use a light source like a
flashlight or a lamp to burn away the
darkness any light source works but your
flashlight can be aimed or focused as
the game calls it letting you burn
quicker but at the cost of battery's
power once it's empty you aren't forced
to replace it though as it recharges on
its own but sometimes the moment calls
for a quick swap doing this leaves them
open to the American special a healthy
dose of 38 special right to the brain a
revolver and flashl are going to be
Allen's goto's for a while until you
find more weapons and the game does a
good job of adding more weapons to spice
things up
you could find the aforementioned
hunting rifle and shotgun for shooting
flares and flashbangs for light and the
most important weapon a flare gun which
serves to solve both problems as while I
personally have't been shot with a flare
gun I can't imagine it feels great
taking one to the chest it sounds like a
typical survival horror game but as I
said it only takes elements from it as
ammo is quite abundant for the most part
assuming you're playing frugally and
since each section is split into
episodes you actually lose your
inventory at the start of each episode
that typical game long feeling about
worrying about running out of ammo only
last as long as the episodes do so once
you start to catch on how it works you
start to become more aggressive and
wasting more batteries and ammo because
you're only going to waste it for that
current episode not the whole game I
think my biggest complaint with the game
playay though is that often times the
hits you take are incredibly cheap most
of the enemies you face like the gados
of Resident Evil love to throw their
axes at you and these guys have some aim
the game is also obsessed with spawning
enemies behind you and while that's not
a problem it's why I call it cheap
sometimes you could Dodge attacks like
it's re3 but outr running them them is
almost out of the question due to Allan
having the lung capacity of someone with
asthma it really starts to show its
flaws when one of the areas later forces
you to run past the enemies instead of
attacking and it's probably where I died
the most as Allen can only Sprint for
about four whole seconds and the enemies
no matter your speed will always catch
up to you I guess it's why I actually
enjoy the health regen system as I can't
imagine I would have been too happy
wasting healing items on damage that
isn't always my fault overall though its
gameplay is solid and also quite unique
as well the concept of chipping down an
enemy's armor foring the weak spot isn't
anything original having light be the
source of it changes things it's
probably the only game I can think of
where the most deadly weapon is a
flashlight and kind of reminds me of
Fatal Frame where a weapon of choice is
a standard everyday object regardless
the sheer originality behind it would
have already been enough to earn some
praise in my book luckily it's also a
joy to play as well returning to where
we left off Allan Wake has just awoken
from a car crash despite the fact that 2
minutes ago he was diving into a lake to
save his wife he also happened to find
the title of a book he was going to
write but apparently already did these
manuscript pages are part of the game's
Collectibles and oddly enough tell the
story of the game before it happens just
about every page you collect explains
something about the story whether that
be an event that is about to happen or
one that already has sometimes though
the pages do talk about other characters
and what they're up to which is usually
something Allan and the player won't
experience it creates this weird feeling
as you sometimes read pages only for it
to happen exactly as it was described
almost like we characters in a book
Rusty kept coughing blood my eyes were
drawn to the twist shape of his broken
leg the attack had been vicious Max
whined in his cage Rusty's eyes were
wild with fear and Terror he gasped Mr
wake it happened just the way it was on
that
page oh hell it happened just the way it
was on that page you'll also notice that
the voiceover you heard was Allan
narrating the story every manuscript
page has a narration like this and most
of the dialogue spoken as narrated by
Allan too giving the player a sense of
what he's thinking in the context of the
story the idea of the characters
speaking like they're a part of the book
is great such as the constant usage of
being overly descriptive when it comes
to a character's emotions or setting the
scene as books often times need to be
this way so the reader can create a
visual image of what's going on what's
rather fascinating about this is that
this style of Storytelling is now a
remedy staple as each of their games
protagonists narrate or comment about
certain events in some
fashion while looking for Alex I had
ended up in the middle of a big- Time
crime
operation because if that's possible POS
our options are very
different Emily
Pope I don't know her but I like her
already oh
[__] something
clicked I could reach out and stop time
in a focused area help me you don't know
what you're doing while I like the way
remedy handles this idea in each of
their games alen Wick's version has
always been more surreal given where the
narration comes from this idea of
surrealism is likely from The Game's
Inspirations and references Alan Wake
wear said things on its sleeve its main
Inspirations are Stephen King's novels
The Twilight Zone and David Lynch's Twin
Peaks and it is not subtle about it
where some games would take from these
things or recreate a famous scene Allan
Wake just straight up has Stephen King
in their universe and also has Allen
reference him
constantly I had to figure a way out of
this any second now and stuck would be
knocking on the door with his ax like
Nicholson in The Shining Allan Wake
while a video game is definitely trying
to make itself out to be a TV production
that's why the chapters are called
episodes or special features and why
each episode starts the classic
previously on Allan Wake it's a game
filled with inspiration so much so that
you could argue that the entire plot of
the game is Just Stephen King's novel
misery which I'll explain later for now
though let's actually continue with the
plot the first episode outside of the
opening moments is quite light on the
details when it comes to the story as is
mainly trying to get the player
accustomed to the gameplay one thing
that's important to mention though is
that you can find a TV that plays a clip
of Allen talking to himself while inside
of another room throughout the game are
also a couple of QR codes that can be
scanned as well the original was a bit
more comical than the remaster with
these links as they were either things
like a conversation about how Allen wck
is good enough to be played even when
not on a couch referring to the game's
PC port or a very 2010 style meme of Sam
Lake making the iconic max pain face but
the remaster changed it to link to
unlisted videos on remedy's YouTube
channel that talk about Allan and his
time in the dark place similar to what
we talked about before regarding the
whole it feels like we're characters in
a book thing it's something that will be
explained later but it gives off the
feeling that not everything is right in
the world at the moment if the shadowy
figures didn't already give it away of
course while making it back to
civilization Alan finds a phone and
calls the sheriff with the hope of
finding Alice once the sheriff arrives
she asks what happened to Carl Stucky
the guy who was supposed to give us the
keys to the cabin Allan is reluctant to
tell her not only because of the Shadow
figures part but because Carl was one of
them and Allan had to kill him so at the
risk of being put in a psych wward or
arrested he holds his tongue the two
then drive back to the cabin hoping to
search for Alice only to find out that
it's not there and that there never was
a cabin on the lake this connects to
something Alice mentions earlier in the
episode where she says that the brochure
mentioned that the cabin was near the
lake not on it now things are really
starting to not make sense and if you
think it's going to light up at some
point you are sadly mistaken it's only
going to get weirder from
here episode 2 starts with a flashback
of Alice and Allen in their New York
City Apartment the couple are quite
creative people which is like they withd
drew them to each other in the first
place as Allen is a writer while Alice
is a photographer this also meant that
Alice was working closely with Allen on
his projects as she would take head
shots and promotional photos for his
upcoming novels the point of this
flashback is to show how even though
they tend to fight both of them still
love each other by having Allan give
Alice a clicker that he was given as a
kid as a way to ward off the darkness
whenever she gets scared returning back
to the present day Allan is being
questioned by the sheriff for regarding
what happened to him last night before
getting a phone call from a person who
claims to have kidnapped Alice they also
want him to stop talking to the police
and for Allan to give him the pages of
the manuscript he is rightfully shocked
by this information not only for the
more obvious reasons but also because of
the manuscript as he's just as confused
about its orgin as him and is shocked to
not anyone else knows about it Allen is
at a bit of a Crossroads thankfully his
agent Barry wheeler comes by and picks
him up Allen that gives him the lowdown
of what's going on here but obviously he
finds it to be ridiculous realizing he
has to do this on his own he sets off to
lovers Peak the location the kidnapper
specified they meet up at eventually he
does meet with the kidnapper but due to
an altercation with the dark presence
the two have to work together Allen with
the flashlight and the kidnapper with
the gun unfortunately the man's a [__]
shot which makes this section very
annoying to complete the two then argue
over Alice in the manuscript before
Allen somehow punches him with enough
Force to knock them both off the
railings and onto the
ground uh sure either way due to them
being split up thanks to this they have
to meet somewhere else which he says
will be the bright Falls Coal Mine a
good portion of this episode and the
next are centered around this situation
and it's not really something I'm a fan
of episode 3 is definitely the worst of
the bunch as it's just a series of go
posts being moved around as alen is
forced to go from one location to the
next as the kidnapper keeps moving the
location like each episode it does have
small things added within it that do
make it an enjoyable experience but the
actual narrative progression of the plot
in this episode is lacking that small
thing I talked about earlier though is
the Cliffhanger at the end of episode 2
which shows Rose the waitress from the
diner asking Barry and Allen to come to
her house at the trailer park as she has
the manuscript pages that the kidnapper
wants before pans around to show the old
lady in Black again implying that she's
not only controlling Rose but that she
has nefarious intentions revolving
around the Two Men episode 3 will then
pick up from there with the two arriving
at her trailer I know it's a game and
the plot needs to progress but it is
always incredibly odd when someone acts
completely out of character and no one
bats an eye to it hey this is really
good Rose yes my manuscript I really
need it I understand I know what you
need amus to inspire you both of them
will eventually discover that Rose lied
about the manuscript but it's too late
as they've been drugged alen then
experiences a dream with a deep SE diver
who talks to him about something taking
over his wife the voice is also eerily
similar to the talking light I briefly
mentioned earlier meaning they're one
and the same what they is though is
still unclear when Allan wakes up he's
greeted by the brightfalls police and an
FBI agent named Nightingale he might be
the funniest character in the whole game
due to his unwavering commitment to his
own bit Nale is familiar with Allen and
his work so when he goes to arrest him
he uses other writers names to make fun
of him like in this scene where he goes
get him up Hemingway you're under arrest
referring to American novelist Ernest
Hemingway he does this numerous times
throughout the game that I don't even
think he ever calls Alan by his real
name
once nowhere to run now Dan Brown you
back away from me don't hurt it who I'll
get you yet even if it kills me you hear
me you hear me HP love CRA I've got you
now Raymond Chandler it's all here all
the evidence including conspiracy to
murder a federal agent there's no way
you're walking out of here you hear me
in there Bret Easton Ellis huh I love
the implication that the man is such a
fan of books and novels that he's able
to name so many famous authors
throughout history due to his love for
the medium because there is no other
explanation for him being able to say a
different author every time on the spot
without fail given his love for books he
probably likes wake's writings too but
he doesn't want to admit that to the guy
he's trying to arrest my only issue with
Nightingale is that like some other
characters a lot of his backstory is
absent in this game due to being in
other material outside of the DLC and
spin-off Allen Wick also got a novel
called Allan Wake a short book called
The Allen wake files and a prequel TV
show bright Falls it's another one of
those situations where certain events or
motivations are revealed in this media
and nowhere else even though they should
be in the game you don't know and won't
ever know why night Andale came to
Bright falls in the first place if you
only played the game as the other media
talks about him having a dream of the
dark place and seeing Alan Wake in those
dreams so we became obsessed with
finding him so he could figure out
what's going on even with that knowledge
Nill doesn't even follow that logic as
he tries to shoot him twice so unless
he's a spiritual medium in his spare
time I don't think he'll be able to talk
to Allen if he's dead without the other
sources n Andale is an agent who's
trying to arrest Allen for an unknown
reason and while I'm glad we at least
got some confirmation about what his
plan was not only should it have been
touched upon in the game the novel the
info comes from is apparently not even
Canon so do with that what you will
either way he's here at the trailer park
to speak to Allan regarding his
experience but now wants to arrest him
seeing his two adult men showed up to a
young girl's house and stayed their way
later than they should have which
doesn't look good Allan isn't exactly
making his case any better by running
immediately after as I said earlier this
is the episode where alen continues to
run from one place to the next hoping to
find the kidnapper before being
instructed to go somewhere else it first
started at lovers Peak then the coal
mine and of course because he didn't
show up there he now has to meet him at
miror Peak Lookout as tedious as the
plot of this episode has been it's at
least accurate to how Allen is feeling
right now so Silver Lining I guess one
thing you will find here though is
another TV but unlike the first one that
had Allen on it this one is of a TV show
called night Springs it's very clearly a
riff on the Twilight Zone as it has a
similar logo style and intro chime both
also deal with strange and mysterious
occurrences like this one where two
ladies are casually staring at a man
who's inside of a portal in the middle
of their basement there is actually one
of these TVs in each episode I just
decided to talk about it now since if I
was to go right into night Springs
during the first episode we would have
been 20 minutes into the video and in
terms of story would have been still at
the car crash so I figured I should you
know at least move on with the goddamn
plot before rambling again my personal
favorite episode though is one titled
Quantum immortality Quantum immortality
is uniquely tied to Quantum suicide as
the idea is that we as humans are are
Immortal as every time we're close to
death we Branch off into another reality
where we didn't for the sake of an
example let's say you get into a car
crash fortunately you're alive maybe
you're hurt and have some broken bones
but alive nonetheless well that might
not be true maybe you actually died but
were sent into another reality in which
you did live this is because of the many
worlds interpretation which is basically
that there are infinite number of
realities and an infinite amount of
possibilities so circling back to the
car crash given there is an infinite
amount of things that can happen there
was a world where you die in a car crash
one where you live and one where the
crash never happened among an infinite
number of other unique scenarios Quantum
immortality claims incidents like this
happen all the time but every time we
have some near-death experience we're
taken out of our reality and put into
another one where we lived or where that
event never happened it's also implied
to be seamless so it's not something you
would ever notice meaning that if you
ever had a near-death experience in your
life you might have actually died in
your reality but were moved to another
where you did night Springs parodies
this by having a guy put a gun to his
head claiming that the gun will never be
able to shoot when pointed at him thanks
to machine he built he proves this by
shooting himself resulting in a blank
before shooting at the ceiling which is
when the bullet fires the gun is also a
standard M9 pistol meaning it should
fire if a bullet is loaded as it doesn't
have a revolving cylinder like a magnum
the episode ends though with one of his
assistants accidentally tripping over
the cord that's connected to the machine
followed by the demonstrator pulling it
once again only to be shot and killed as
he was too focused on proving his point
to his colleagues that he didn't hear
his assistant's comment what does this
have to do with the story of Alan Wake
honestly nothing but I love talking
about hyp iCal questions like this
although assuming the theory is true you
could claim that every time you're close
to death in this game Allan is not
simply alive but actually died and was
just moved to another reality one where
he survived his encounter with the taken
Food For Thought getting back to the
story once Allan finally arrives at
miror Peak he and the kidnapper meet but
he seems to be freaking out and claims
that he never kidnapped Alice to begin
with the dark presence then arrives
which blows Allen off the Lookout Point
and into the water he's then once again
visited by the deep sea diver before
episode 3 comes to a close
episode 4 has Allan waking up next to a
Dr Emil Hartman he is someone we saw
earlier before Allan socked him in the
head he has a tendency to do that it
seems the reason was that Alice felt
that Allan needed counseling to fix the
writer's block and talk to Dr Hartman
since he claims to specialize in
creatives this is likely the reason
behind brif Falls being the couple's
vacation destination as Alice probably
saw Dr Hartman's work looked him up and
then found out that he resides in bright
Falls which also means that her whole
plan was to get Allan help and not
simply relax I'm sure that relaxing on
vacation was a part of the plan but it
wasn't the only step it seems which
connects to the typewriter gift that she
gave him well Allan found that Alice
wanted to get him help by using Dr
Hartman and hit him for convincing his
wife that he needed such help fast
forward to now when Dr Hartman is now
treating him for those exact reasons Dr
Hartman is a therapist who specializes
in creatives like artists writers and
game devs bit of an odd specialty but it
makes sense when his motivations are
taken into account Harmon immediately
starts the conversation by saying Alice
is dead and that she drowned making our
attempts to rescue her pointless he also
claims that Allan is suffering from
severe hallucinations regarding things
centered around Supernatural forces of
darkness which is exactly what we're
going through Allan and likely the
player don't believe a word he says and
they shouldn't Hartman is trying to use
Allan for his own gain so that he can
manipulate the dark place a supernatural
plane of existence in all fairness
though he is right about Alice she isn't
technically dead but she is trapped in
the dark place so us trying to find her
like we've been doing has been fruitless
but Allan isn't the only patient that
Hartman's trying to use the two patients
that are actually important are the
Anderson Brothers named Odin and Tor as
they have a history with the dark place
and the supernatural entities that we've
been fighting that's why upon meeting
Allan they tell him to visit their Farm
as they have a secret message for him
the less important but more comical
patient is The Game Dev who talks about
his experience with a previous game he
worked on he talks about how Publishers
don't know [__] about game design and
how they only want to add things to the
game so they could say they contributed
without thinking of the ramifications it
can have like how One publisher wanted
to add mullets to the game because they
thought it'd be funny and then when the
game is in slow motion they could call
it mullet time because according to them
that name was a hook for their
demographic this is clearly referring to
Max pay's Bulet time mechanic the mullet
part though was apparently something
that actually happened according to an
old tweet from one of the original
developers in which mullet time was
considered for the game since it was
going to combine Max Payne's bullet time
with alen Wick's redneck setting while
the game does have no shortage of slow
motion shots bullet time style slow
motion never made it and likely for good
reason after Allan is done looking
around the building he is then ESC Ed by
one of the staff members to his room
before immediately trying to escape
Allan while escaping also runs into
Barry who came by to get him out before
being taken by Hartman's men who stuffed
him in the room this leads into an
incredibly long Chase throughout the
woods as well as a large concert using
the Anderson Brothers Old Stage once
inside the radio plays a song by the
brothers that says find the lady of the
night that's how you reshave Destiny
this lady of the light is Cynthia Weaver
who we also briefly saw in the first
episode they assume that she's somewhere
back in bright Falls but it's getting a
bit late so the two are going to start
the search tomorrow morning in the
meantime they decide to drink their
brother's extremely potent moonshine
which causes them to pass out what Allan
sees after his a vision of what happened
to Alice which shows him diving into the
water but instead of waking up in the
car crash he's then getting out of the
water and then goes upstairs before
meeting with that old lady in Black who
then tells them that he can use the
typewriter to get Alice back from the
dark place so he writes a story the
title of it is called departure the name
of the manuscript Pages we've been
finding and the entire plot of the game
with the big twist Finally Revealed
let's take a step back and get you up to
speed years ago a couple came to
brightfalls for a vacation their names
were Thomas Zayn and Barbara Jagger
Thomas is the deep sea diver we've been
seeing and Barbara is the lady in Black
however one day Barbara drowned in the
lake the same one that took Alice Thomas
was distraught when he heard about the
news but through Dr Emil Hartman he
figured out a way to get her back see
cauldron Lake the one that surrounds the
cabin is basically a portal that
transports those who enter it into a
place called the dark place a
supernatural plane of existence that is
different from our own Dr Hartman
somehow learned about its Supernatural
powers and sought to control it which is
why he specializes in creatives because
for some odd reason the dark place
responds to creative works by using them
as a means to shape reality remember
when we talked about the pages of the
manuscript spelling out the plot that
happened before us that's because the
pages Alan wrote while in the dark place
reshape reality well after talking with
Dr Hartman Thomas Zayn decided to use
his skill of poetry to get Barbara back
this however came with the unintended
consequence of an unknown entity known
as the dark presence coming through and
taking over Barbara body while the dark
place is simply a place the dark
presence is a formless entity that
resides in the dark place the dark
presence uses the writings and creative
works that flow through the dark place
in order to achieve its goals Thomas
Zayn realized what was happening so
using his poems he created a story that
saw him in the dark presence why from
existence he had to do it this way or
the dark presence was going to escape
and wreck havoc upon the world from then
on Thomas would disappear from the world
along with the dark presence that had
previously used his wife's body as a
puppet Thomas Zayn like his lover though
would also be taken by another presence
this one called the bright presence I'll
explain some of this later but the dark
place needs to have balance things can't
be taken without at least giving
something up in that same vein a dark
presence cannot exist without a bright
presence as light and dark are Polar
Opposites of each other at the time
neither of the entities had forms but
now the wife is being used by the dark
and the husband the light I should
clarify though that this Thomas isn't
actually Thomas just the bright presence
using his body as a form an ARG for the
game called the house of Dreams say that
Thomas ended up making a baby unit
iverse where him and Barbara are
together again implying that they are
gone from this world this means that the
deep sea diver we meet is just the
bright presence well it is a nicer
entity than the dark presence we still
don't know what its motivations are
outside of wanting to defeat the dark
presence regardless the dark presence
and Thomas would then disappear from the
world it wasn't until the 1970s when the
Anderson brothers and their band the old
gods of Asgard would come by and also do
battle with the dark presence how they
succeeded is also never explained but
they were successful in stopping it once
again it would then lay dormant until
the arrival of Alan Wake Allan and Alice
would then arrive at The Cauldron Lake
Alice falls into the lake and Allan
Dives in after her but instead of
staying in the real world he's then
transported into the dark place this is
where he would meet with Barbara who is
once again just the dark presence using
her body to tell Allan how to save Alice
the same thing Thomas Zayn tried to do
in actuality the dark presence had no
plans of making Allan save Alice those
TVs we find of Allen are him talking to
himself about what's going on and he
mentions how Barbara is making edits to
his story the dark presence is trying to
get Allan to release it into the real
world under the guise of rescuing Alice
if the dark presence gets its way and
Allan plays along he'll be trapped here
Alice will still be dead and the dark
presence will be released into the real
world Alan after a few days of writing
discovered exactly what we just talked
about that the dark presence was trying
to manipulate him so now he's trying to
make edits to the story the problem is
that there are stipulations to make
things simple the magic of using
creative Works to change reality won't
work unless it's a proper piece of work
realistically the dark presence could
make Allen right and then the dark
presence leaves the dark place place and
destroys the world the end but that
wouldn't work though because if you
think about it from a meta perspective
that being the end of a story would suck
and thus the magic won't work the story
has to have actual tension drama stakes
and character motivations furthermore
just as he can't McGuffin his way out of
a situation he also can't create
something to help him either Allen isn't
allowed to just summon a minigun and
then start blasting his way through
bright Falls he can only create the idea
of something so if Allen needs a bridge
to cross a river instead of it just
creating one maybe a piece of debris
explodes ends up creating a bridge in
instead he also can't go and edit the
already existing Pages either say for
example you and I were going to write a
story but we switched off every page
meaning I got all the even pages and you
got all the odd well naturally you and I
would have different ideas for the story
but since we can change what the other
wrote I have to somehow guide the story
back to the way I want which would then
be Fall by you trying to guide the story
back to where you want this is what
Allan is doing with the dark presence he
had already written a few days worth of
pages based on what the dark presence
wanted so now he has to continue the
story make it a decently written one
that can't be Sol any kind of DSX MAA
while also guiding it back to where
Allan wants the story to go that he can
win and beat the dark presence it's
probably why remedy decided to use a
typewriter as the machine as typewriters
physically imprint the ink onto the
pages meaning mistakes can't be undone
just as Alan can't undo the work he has
already done for the dark presence this
story that he is writing is of course
what we go through after the car crash
Allan is basically writing a story about
himself wherein he fights the dark
presence and its minions kills the
entity and escapes the dark place that's
what Allan has been doing because his
writings can change reality thanks to
the power of the dark place and is why
everything he wrote down in the
manuscripts has already happened Allen
then wrote this book which is once again
the entire plot of the game so far for a
whole week until the bright presence
still using the form of Thomas Zayn came
by to distract the dark presence Allen
then used this as an opportunity to
escape so he ran outside of the cabin
and took a car before getting into a car
crash which is what happened all the way
back in episode 1 that is the real story
of Alan Wake circling back to an earlier
comment of mine this is why I said that
the game's plot is Lucy based around
Stephen King's misery as Allen is trying
to write his way out of imprisonment
within the dark place using his writing
skills misery Stars famous author Paul
Sheldon who early on in the story gets
into a car accident fortunately a nurse
named an wils played by Cathy Bates in
the film adaptation happened to be
nearby and was able to rescue him from
his car and take him back to her place
unfortunately she's a crazed fan of his
who sees that the ending of his new book
series to kill off the main character so
she locks him in a room and forces Paul
to rewrite the story in a way that she
likes similar to Allan Paul also has to
make could flow well as he tries to rush
the ending which annoys her even more
eventually it ends with him killing Anne
escaping and then publishing a new story
not within the misery series which ends
up being quite successful what's rather
interesting about this is that this
isn't the only game to take a page out
of the story as Resident Evil 7's
bedroom DLC also has elements of misery
in it one of the more iconic scenes in
the story sees Paul trying to escape
from the house when Anne steps out for
the day this proves to be quite
difficult as the crash severely injured
him to make matters worse and to come
back a bit earlier than he thought so we
had to put everything back the way it it
was or she find out he tried escaping he
puts everything back perfectly except
one ceramic penguin That's facing the
wrong direction as punishment she bashes
his leg in with a hammer whereas Al way
takes the writing your way out of your
own personal prison part bedroom in
classical resin evil fashion takes the
leg bashing part as you play another
victim of the baker's Clancy who's
trying to escape the bedroom before
margar finds out just like with Paul
there are certain steps in the Escape
process that can act as points of no
return where margarite will come by and
check on you so you have to remember
what the room looked like before you
started rearranging everything and if
she catches you she will not be happy
it's cool to see other games takes on
the concept as is a genuinely great film
I might even go as far as to say it's
one of Kathy bates's best roles but
seeing as she's been in over a 100
different Productions since the 70s
that's going to be a hard choice to make
getting back to Allan we along with him
now understand what happened between him
diving into the water and him waking up
in the car crash he still doesn't seem
too familiar with the events of the
story even though he wrote them but he
does recall not finishing the ending
which is his new objective Ive return to
the cabin and finish the story to get
there though we have to find Cynthia
Weaver who is that lady of the light the
Anderson Brothers refer to in their song
upon waking up from The Nightmare though
he is then greeted by the gun of agent
Nightingale who puts him under arrest
episode 5 starts right after this with
Allan and Barry in prison Nightingale
also seems to have taken the manuscript
Pages as he recalls some of the events
that are happening right as he's
speaking about those said events it then
ends with him being taken by the dark
presence just like before he doesn't
waste any time calling him by another
writer name but I do like the nice touch
of his last words calling Allen Stephen
King seeing as he was the game's biggest
inspiration unlike night Andale Sheriff
breaker believes Allen and like the
kidnapper is going to be killing the
taken alongside us thankfully she is a
much better shot than him and for maybe
the first time ever is more self-aware
than any MPC I've ever seen as partway
through she and Allen are stuck and need
to get through a locked door but instead
of the typical video game cliche where
we defend while they open the door she's
actually smart enough to recognize the
helping us first would make opening the
door easier due to her being under less
stress I literally couldn't believe it
Sheriff breaker also tells us that
Cynthia Weaver lives at a decommission
power plant because yeah that makes
sense and then further adds that we can
go there via Chopper if we can get to
one a large chunk of this episode is
going to be centered around us running
through the derc streets of bright Falls
to get to that Chopper given what we
talked about earlier regarding the dark
place I should clarify that everything
we've done outside of that cabin has
been in the real world so it's not like
we're still trapped in there from the
car crash to now we've been in the
normal everyday bright Falls it's like
why remedy set the game at night outside
of the darkness and taken thing as many
people would be asleep and not hear the
dozens of bullets going off in fact this
episode actually plays into this as it's
the first time we started shooting near
the town and one of the residents
assumes it's people just celebrating
deer Fest early by shooting off a few
rounds into the sky since you know
Supernatural things like this aren't
normal so we shouldn't expect the
residents to think that that's what's
going on after about an hour of
back-to-back combat encounters we then
meet with Cynthia Weaver she's here to
direct us to the well-lit room a place
created by Thomas for the next person to
find Cynthia has also been helping us
along the way as she's the one leaving
all those yellow markings throughout the
forest that usually lead to extra ammo
and batteries it's here where she
explains what happened to Thomas which
we talked about earlier about how
Barbara died and how he tried to get her
back inside the wellet room though is a
single shoe box with the clicker in it
the same one Allan gave to Alice which
as we know was originally given to Allan
by his mother well this was actually
designed by Thomas as before he died he
wrote in a loophole that says everything
about him in the dark presence would be
erased from existence except for the
items in the shoe box which is the
clicker along with a manuscript page
that details the time Allan received the
clicker from his mom this is where
things start to get confusing to say the
least this implies that Thomas Zayn
created Alan Wake but we know that's not
possible as we've already discussed how
things can just be created out of thin
air so Alan Wake wasn't magically made
by Thomas Zayn but that begs the
question how was the clicker here and
how did Thomas know about it well kby
assumed that while he didn't create
Allen wake he nudged him enough in his
life that it lined up with him going to
Bright Falls like giving him rudder's
block for example but even that is
strange because remember the entire plot
of the game is a copy of the manuscript
that Allan wrote during that weekl long
stay in the dark place so that would
mean that part of the story Allan wrote
is about him creating Thomas Zayn who
then writes his poems at bride Falls
only to have Thomas guide Allen to
brightfalls which leads to the start of
the game but that doesn't make sense
either because once again you can't
create things out of thin air and thas
Zayn and his battle with the dark
presence was done in over with likely
before Allan was even born so that's not
possible some have even gone as far as
to say that Allen and Thomas are the
same person or that Thomas is Allen's
father the latter is only because Allan
never met his father and these two
clearly have a connection of some kind
but the former is based on the fact that
the Anderson Brothers call him Tom
instead of Allan and dialogue right at
the end of the game has Thomas arguing
with Barbara saying you're not Barbara
you came back wrong referring to the
dark presence taking over her body
instead of just coming back to normal
like he wanted but the person speaking
is alen not Tom like I said confusing
it's one of the game's many unanswered
questions questions and it's something
fans of the game still discuss today as
remedy has yet to give an official
answer if I were to throw my two cents
into this unending pool of Darkness I
think Thomas and Allan collaborated on
this incident Allan wrote a manuscript
page about the clicker and its
significance to Alice Thomas luckily saw
this and was able to make the clicker
appear for Allen if we assume Thomas was
the one who nudged Allen to arrive in
Bride Falls then that tracks but if we
assume that Allan was the one who's been
nudging the story then it's possible
that he wrote about Thomas who himself
wrote about the clicker and played it
there for Alan sort of like he
controlled him to get him an object he
would need for later it's not the most
clear-cut explanation but it's all I've
got I think what really makes all this
Troublesome is figuring out what's
involved in the story we have the
manuscript pages to read though but we
don't know how much of the world's
events were created by Allan did he make
Thomas Zayn in the dark presence fight
or was that something that already
happened it's not worth establishing a
beginning for the book either CU you
could always write flashback moments to
give context which is actually what Alan
Wake does as page one starts with the
nightmare he received received right in
the beginning of the game but page 40 or
so talks about Thomas and Barbara So
figuring out what Allan did or did not
create in the story is practically
impossible either way let me know what
you think as there are no wrong answers
here thanks to there being no answer to
begin with with the clicker in hand
though Allan can now go back to the
cabin to defeat Barbara aka the dark
presence and write this ending Barry
naturally asks why he can't just write a
here but Allan clarifies that not only
is the page unfinished and is still on
the typewriter but he also has to be
thorough about this as Thomas cut
Corners in his work which is why to
scrap the whole thing and remove himself
from existence given the shoe box
loophole idea he had Thomas likely
wanted the next person who in this case
would be Allen to stop the dark presence
but also learn from his mistakes don't
cut Corners like he did at the center of
the lake this time is not the cabin but
a giant tornado destroying it then sends
Allen into the dark place inside he
meets with the bright presence who tells
him to go to the cabin before he leaves
he gets introduced to another Allan
called Mr scratch who will apparently
greet his friends once he's gone forgive
me for passing by this insane Revelation
but we're going to have to Circle back
to that statement later as the
implications are far too much to discuss
now afterward we go through a few
sections where we use our light to burn
Words which summon whatever the words
spell out before Alan meets with the
dark presence use the clicker and
defeats it or at the very least
relinquishes its control over Barbara's
body with everything finished Allan sits
down and writes the ending but he
realizes as he's typing that things need
to have balance cause an effect guilt
and atonement stuff like that this is
why Allan decides to swap places with
Alice the ending of departure rewrites
the event of Alan Wake said Allan is the
one who died not Alice Thomas tried to
take someone who died and make them
alive again but didn't take someone
alive and turn them dead he was just
taking without giving back thus
disrupting the balance of the world
Allen's ending keeps the balance instead
of Allen alive and Alice dead it's the
other way around one of the couple is
still dead while the other is alive
meaning the balance is still stable
since he's in the dark place though this
seems to create some kind of loophole
allowing him to still be alive but just
stuck inside the dark place meaning all
he has to do now is just escape and he
and Alice can be together again again
the final scene then shows the town of
Bri Falls celebrating their annual deer
fest with Rose Looking eily similar to
Cynthia Weaver in the way she holds the
lamp with agent Nightingale watching
over her in the background who seems to
have L his prior encounter with the dark
presence sadly neither of these two will
make another appearance in both the DL
seas and spin-off so this will likely be
elaborated on in Allen wake 2 speaking
of that additional content they continue
Allen's story as he attempts to escape
the dark place but before we transition
over to that I want to talk about the
base game for a moment I think it's
pretty clear why I stand with Alan Wake
it's why the word in the thumbnail is
bizarre it's probably the best word I
can use to summarize my experience with
Alan Wake the Crossovers between
survival horror and action coupled with
the story within a story narrative that
has so many twists and turns it makes it
hard to keep up make it one of the most
original games ever created for all of
its Inspirations some of which are more
on the nose than others alen Wick is a
one-of-kind experience and is one of my
favorite games of all time I remember
really enjoying my time with it years
ago and I'm glad I still hold the same
opinion about it today the storytelling
and characters were incred inedible and
are created with such care each
character is so distinct that I really
had trouble remembering someone as I
could easily recall a unique personality
trait or scene that they appeared in
Allan as a protagonist is just as
incredible a sort of everyday guy thrown
into his own hell who's forced to use
his intellect of Storytelling to write
his own story it takes something that
Allen is a professional at and puts his
wits to the test from the gameplay to
the story everything about Allan Wake oo
his originality and is one of the
reasons why I have such a fascination
with this game even if I end up
disliking them I always appreciate when
games go that extra and create something
the world has never seen before it's all
too easy these days to make something
basic or just reuse old ideas for the
years to come but remedy has never been
one to do that though as each of their
games always feel like the contrary and
Allan Wake is no exception Allan's
relationship with writers block and how
that related to my burnout was also a
unique coincidence I didn't expect to
relate to but in a way both of us are
likely getting what we want Allan needed
this interaction to happen as much as he
would disagree as it was the kick he
needed to get his ass back to writing
the guy went from writing not a single
word in 2 years to a whole story story
in a week and while I didn't suffer as
badly as him writing about Alan Wake and
his struggle has been a nice change of
pace compared to the stuff I was making
a few months ago sometimes the unique
event needs to occur for things to
change unlike Allen though I didn't have
a supernatural entity hellbent on
killing me and speaking of which it's
probably time we get back to the story
so we can see what happens on Alan
wake's
Journey after the release of the game
Allan Wake would receive two dlc's that
add two episodes both episodes are
connected as they follow Alan Wake and
his attempt to wrestle with his mind
after being confined to the dark place I
know this is a bit fast but the ending
of the DLC has Allen meeting with
himself in the dark place basically
we're in Allen's mind trying to find
balance so he can focus on writing his
next story being in a foreign
environment such as this would naturally
cause someone to go mad which is why the
DLC focuses on this specific task keep
Allen from losing his mind everything we
experience is in his mind it's just a
more visual version of it cuz without
that the whole DLC would be alen rolling
on the floor talking to himself
therefore the antagonist of this DLC is
Allan himself not the the one from
earlier we'll talk about him soon but
literally him Allen is battling his own
mind the Allen on the TV is the part of
him that wants to give into the dark
place and be one with it while the other
Allen the one that we control is the
other part of his mind that wants to
reject the dark place the DLC from start
to finish is going to be Allan looking
for a way out while constantly being
harassed by himself given that a world
famous writer is now the antagonist the
level design is going to be a lot more
creative than before I like to think of
both the DLCs in American Nightmare as
experimental anyone who's played the
games could probably test the fact that
the game is extremely focused on one
thing when it comes to gameplay while
the game may have the odd change here
and there like using a car or maybe a
lamp as a light source 99% of the game
is based around this flashlight and your
guns these future pieces of additional
content attend to experiment with this
idea to see how far they could push the
game's design as for the DLC remedy
tried to see how far they could push the
game while still staying in its own
boundaries as the gameplay Loop is still
the same but how it's achieved is
different the dlc's take that word
premise from the last 10 minutes of the
base game and stretches that over the
course of the whole whole experience
rarely will you find an item gun or even
ammo without at least coming from these
words due to this the game is able to
change how combat encounters are tackled
there seems to be more enemies and less
ammo this time around as I found myself
being Corner more while also having to
switch weapons more frequently unlike
the main game we also don't find
manuscript Pages things they taking
place all in his head instead we find a
brief clip from the TV Allen that talks
about our next encounter it does tend to
spoil the surprise a bit but I still
think it manages to work every so often
due to the placement of the words take
these next few encounters as an example
under the church is a room filled with
furnaces each of them has the word blast
taped to the door when destroyed it
releases a fiery explosion in a straight
line which is perfect for dealing with
the hordes of enemies in here but it's
just as deadly to the taken as it is to
you especially since a few of the
sections have tight hallways so not only
is the current furnace exploding but the
light is also bright enough to blow up
the one directly in front of it similar
to this is another area that is an open
plane filled with words there are some
words like enemy which spawns taken
Raven which spawns birds and boom which
releases a bright flash AK came a flash
bang the enemy of this location is one
flock of birds which on its own isn't
too Troublesome but given that the birds
fly around everywhere you might
accidentally spawn another flock by
accident furthermore the bright flash
from the boom would not only produce
enough light to burn the words
surrounding it but it might even cause a
chain reaction of other flashes if you
aren't careful these aren't the only
changes the DLC makes just the ones that
stood out as there is a new enemy type
which goes invisible when covered in
darkness an arena covered in lamp posts
that flicker on and off allowing you to
use them as weapons and even just minor
changes to more basic areas like this
Warehouse that has extremely narrow
walkways making combat more
claustrophobic well not too interested
in the words as a concept the
experimentation going on here is
remarkable I think a large reason why I
wasn't super into the idea was because
it feels like a mechanic that excels in
small numbers having almost every area
include these words is a bit exhausting
but if they instead had them pop up
every now and then that might be better
I do honestly hope though that this does
come back for the sequel as I can see it
getting fully realized as long as
they're in short bursts
as for the story Allan has stated before
is going through his own mind in an
attempt to battle back the dark thoughts
of him wanting to be taken by the dark
place while literally this is Allan
thinking his way out of the problem
metaphorically we're going in and
shooting the taken aka the dark thoughts
in order to save him this presents quite
a unique approach to the story as that
means everything we see is coming from
Allen's mind we end up going through
some old locations as they're familiar
to Allan and we'll also meet some old
characters but it's not the old cast
directly more so how Allan perceives
them Barry shows up about halfway
through the first episode when is
struggling to understand what's going on
he claims that it's all in his mind and
that's why he's here before Allan
replies with I must love punishment then
what is likely happening is that Allan
for as much as he and Barry May fight
finds comfort in having a friend here by
his side to further play into the
memories part the game also has a few
flashbacks like the one where he and
Alice are taking photos for the new book
alen followed this up by saying it was a
great memory I wish I didn't see it
Ellen probably doesn't want to think
about the good times since he's
currently in the worst time of his life
and may never be able to go back to
those times by far the worst one is a
conversation between Hartman and TV
Allen where the two play a call from
Alice who berates him for how he treated
her you for your childish temper and the
arrogance and self-indulgent pride that
undermined all efforts to drag you out
of the hole you insisted on digging for
yourself I hate you for leaving me in
the dark with that insane monster [__]
all you had to do was act like a loving
human being for once in your life and
stay with me if your traumatic exit
hadn't been more important then making
sure I was all right she would never
have taken me I don't know where you
went but that's okay I don't want to
know I don't think I'll ever be all
right the only thing that keeps me from
killing myself is the hope that I'll
never see you
again ouch I I just can't argue with
that I think I should stay here before I
ruin what life she has left it's
important to remember that Alice never
said this it's just Alan thinking about
Alice and what she thinks of him as
humans we tend to think of the worst
possible outcomes and obsess over things
until they feed on us this is what Allan
is doing that bad part of him wants to
stay here in the dark place away from
Alice because he thinks that she'd be
better off without him that other part
of him though doesn't want that he
didn't waste all this time and effort to
get her back just to leave her alone so
no matter what it takes he's going to
get out of this place the final fight of
this DLC is figh a shadowy version of
Allen's friends which are just
manifestations of Allen's negative
thoughts towards himself before coming
face to face with himself this is where
the reveal about all this being and his
head comes in but now that he's gotten
his mind stable he's ready and calm he's
in complete Zen if you will no more
negative thoughts and no more worries
all that matters is just getting out of
here which is when he starts to write
the next book return for it only lasting
a couple of hours the DLC episodes are
quite fun the combat was great and the
new word mechanic was interesting enough
for me to hopefully see it return in the
sequel the story while not as impressive
as the base game is a direct
continuation so it's actually going to
not be as interesting due to the mystery
already being revealed even with its
focused story though it was was still
able to give us a tease of the events to
come as Allen is in the process of
wuning his escape from the dark place
again which is where American Nightmare
begins American Nightmare is technically
considered a direct sequel to the
original game but given we already have
a proper sequel on the way it's best to
call it a spin-off I like to think of
American Nightmare as Allen wake 1.5 a
bridge to close the gap between the two
games that it gives us context as the
how we go from one to the other this
time instead of battling his mind
Allen's going to have to battle his
doppelganger Mr scratch for a long time
though I wrote off American Nightmare as
a really boring spin-off but it was only
until very recently that I realized I'd
gotten it mixed up with another game
spin-off also set in bum [__] USA which
was Dead Rising 2's K zero how I managed
to mix these games up is one of life's
greatest Mysteries I'm afraid I was
still correct about the K zero thing to
be fair as I feel like Dead Rising 2
really excels over a long period of time
as it allows the player to experiment
and gain better weapons whereas K zero
can be finished in about 2 hours but
with American Nightmare I was slightly
off off I'm still not a huge fan of the
game but it's definitely not as boring
as my delusional mind used to think it
takes about two whole minutes to realize
how different things are when compared
to the original American Nightmare is
more focused on action as it throws more
hordes at the player than ever before
and the gun types have been massively
increased instead of a pistol and
shotgun there is now a nail gun an SMG
an assault rifle and even a full auto
shotgun the flashlight also no longer
chips away at the darkness simply by
aiming you can only damage them by
focusing The Beam with the trade-off
being that it recharges faster than ever
before along with with new weapons are
also new enemies like these big
hillbilly chainsaw guys and one of the
more distinct creatures being this taken
that can transform into a flock of birds
to avoid damage the game even manages to
bring back the open world concept as
each level could be explored freely
allowing me to look around for more
manuscript Pages which is going to be
important is there what gives you access
to the new arsenal of weapons if the
base game was a mix of survival horror
and action American Nightmare would be
Allen wake's formula with full-on action
just like the dlc's were experiments to
see how far they could push the game
while still keeping its core values
American Nightmare is about seeing how
far remedy could push the game before it
goes completely off the cliff
unfortunately while I didn't mind it too
much I much prefer the more methodical
and slow combat from the original in
fact in an interview with Sam Lake he
says that allenway 2 is going to be more
survival horror focused which means each
game in the series now fits on different
points on the gameplay Spectrum so you
might have brain damage you're about to
do great things with a magic piece of
paper and you came here from another
dimension no I'm from New York I I was
just visiting another dimension as for
the story American Nightmare is a spin
on an episode of night Springs which in
and of itself is just the game's version
of The Twilight Zone Allan used to do
work for night Springs and did some
writing for the show before going solo
one of the stories was about a warrior
of light taking on the forces of dark
which is what the story of American
Nightmare is all about our Champions are
Alan Wake and Mr scratch one of light
and one of dark we saw Mr scratch at the
end of the game very briefly but we
didn't get a chance to talk about him it
sounds like an actual joke but I truly
mean this when I say it is not far off
to call Mr scratch evil Allan Wake he is
the physical manifestation of all of
Alan wake's worst qualities whether he
has them or not when Alan Wake
disappeared into the dark place many
likely wondered where he went the dark
place was then able to take those
stories and ideas and create Mr scratch
it's also implied that the bright
presence created him as a way to balance
the dark place back in the base game
when we first saw him it said that he
would greet Allen's friends while he was
gone similar to how Allan traded places
with Alice to keep the balance Mr
scratch is likely another type of
balance
Allen stays in the dark place but
nothing from the dark place is coming
out which is why Mr scratch was created
and then released admittedly though all
of that is speculation as his
motivations are completely unknown and
American Nightmare doesn't attempt to
answer any of it either despite that
though he is such a good villain his
whole stick at least for this game is to
make Allen's life a living nightmare he
remarks on how he's probably going to
kill Barry when he sees him since he's
annoying as [__] as well as play the
role of Allan to deceive Alice only to
kill her once he gets bored we also get
to see some of his action through the TV
and the guy is a complete
Maniac I know they all say that
right and she's giving me the eye so I
make a couple of moves we have a couple
of drinks and then things start
happening but I say I have to go to the
bathroom
first uhoh
right she's got no
idea watch this this is going to be
Priceless hey don't stop it's just
getting
good watch
[Music]
this yeah did you see
that oh man did you see her
Bo
else Animals As for what the story
actually focuses on well it's basically
Mr scratch and alen wake fighting while
the two are trapped in a Time Loop
American Nightmare has three acts with
three chapters each chapter is the same
location meaning you'll visit each
location three times surprisingly the
game actually has enough insight to
recognize that would be boring as hell
to do three times over so the game has
you skipped the objectives each time you
go through the loop for example in act
one for reasons that are still beyond my
comprehension Alan has to place a CD in
a boom box turn the valve on an oil dere
and flick warning lights on which
somehow cause a meteor to crash into a
satellite which itself crashes into an
oil dere destroying it in the process
you'll also have to do this again in act
two but one of the NPCs here remembers
the past Loop and puts together some of
the puzzle for you so you only need to
get the batteries for the lights then in
act three the whole thing is already
complete so you just need to start the
activation sequence it still doesn't
make the whole thing any less tedious
but they at least try to make the
subsequent runs a bit better the whole
objective here here is to go to the
observatory and print out a signal which
is supposed to tell Allan what to do
when he gets to the drive-in theater
these steps are supposed to stop Mr
scratch and give Allen away out of the
dark place the issue is that the first
two runs don't give you the complete
picture so you have to go through the
whole thing multiple times to get the
last piece of the puzzle through this
mechanic American Nightmare also proves
a longstanding argument of mine and
that's that a bad game doesn't always
have bad ideas back in 2018 Bethesda
release Fallout 76 which was universally
regarded as an awful game while I
personally think it's gotten better over
the years I'm aware enough to recognize
that by multiplayer and Fallout
standards it's not that great still it
was able to improve a system from the
previous game Fallout 4 since the main
objective of that game is to be a little
more than a trash hoarder you'll find
yourself picking up every random object
in existence sometimes though you end up
picking up an item you didn't want but
to drop it you have to find what tab in
the inventory the item belongs to
assuming of course you even remember
what you grabbed Fallout 76 added a new
tab in the inventory called new which
shows all the items you picked up and
orders them by how recently you grab
them this was such a great mechanic
stuck in a mediocre game which is why
I'm glad Bethesda recognized its
potential and put it in Starfield remedy
seems to have done this exact thing with
American Nightmare as the scene setting
you do throughout this DLC may have made
its way into the sequel while it's not
out yet so we can't be completely sure
how this mechanical function alen seems
to be able to take scenes from other
places and write them into his story
which in gameplay will allow you to
change the full scene possibly giving
you an exit that was otherwise blocked
it's why at the end of the day I
appreciate what both the DLCs and
American Nightmare tried to do as they
allow remedy to essentially throw [__]
at the wall to see what sticks without
compromising the Integrity of the main
game the open World style didn't work
for the base game but there's no harm in
trying it again in a small or more
compact title I still don't think it's
amazing even in American Nightmare as I
much prefer the linearity of the
original game but it was a valiant
attempt regardless while going through
the loops though you start to realize
that the people here seem to recall the
past Loops such as this girl Emma Sloan
who remembers that she died in a
previous loop it's never really
explained why unfortunately but this
does seem to take place inside the dark
dark place what is also not explained is
some of the things that are talked about
within the DLC like how Barry now
manages the Anderson Brothers who are
back to writing music or how Barry and
Alice are trying to figure out what to
do with alen's work now that he's dead I
don't recall the game ever mentioning
how Allen is able to know what is
happening in the real world outside of
the dark place or if all this stuff is
just part of his story since remember
this whole plot is just a part of his
new book Return which we saw at the end
of the DLC it's another Thomas Zayn
situation where the line between what is
and what isn't a part of Allen's story
is quite blurry all this ends with Allan
finally completing the puzzle which
plays a film Real Alice made of Allen
and her as a memorial given his passing
this was somehow able to defeat Mr
scratch ending the loop the final scene
then shows Allan and Alice embracing one
another as he's finally able to escape
the dark place and be reunited with the
love of his life or that's what he
thought would happen both control and
Alan W 2 confirm this but that last
scene didn't happen it's what Alan
wished happened he's unfortunately still
stuck in the dark place with no idea if
he'll ever get out American Nightmare
while not the best product out there was
a nice experimental attempt at expanding
Alan wake's gameplay while also giving
remedy more opportunities to use their
unique styles of Storytelling to create
more mind-bending Tales Allan Wake the
special features and American Nightmare
are all wonderful examples of how
impressive remedy is it making games
while I wouldn't exactly call Allen wake
underrated it's definitely a game that
should have had more mainstream
attention it's a one-of-kind piece of
work and I hope this video proves why if
it wasn't clear from the type of games I
tend to talk about here the more complex
the story is the more I'm intrigued and
while it doesn't automatically mean a
basic story is bad a complex story
usually applies some kind of original
idea that makes it complex whether it be
from software's uses of item
descriptions kojima's style a plot twist
in double crosses or remedy's attempt at
making a story within a story where the
author plays the protagonist who acts
out everything he just wrote It's all
interesting enough for me to at least
look at it and say where the hell is
this going to go alen wake was and
always has been a great game to me I
love the original back in the day and I
enjoyed the remaster just as much its
gameplay was engaging and its story can
be very hard to piece together which
ultimately makes this quite difficult to
talk about as alen wake isn't just a
small series anymore as a new entry
would further expand the universe and
I'm not talking about the
sequel for years there was a theory that
all of remedy's games were connected in
what's been called the remedy connected
Universe for a while it was just
speculation and fan Theory such as how
different characters are play by the
same actor Like Jesse feden protagonist
of control who shares the same actress
with Quantum breaks Beth Wild
this wouldn't be confirmed though until
control as its second DLC awe Stars Alan
Wake before we get there though I want
to give a brief rund on of what control
is all about I won't be critiquing it or
going as in- depth with it like I did
with Alan Wick though as I'll likely
save there for a future video still I
want to at least catalog what Allan was
doing in this DLC while we're here as
the events of both games could play a
role in Allen W 2's narrative control
Stars protagonist Jesse feden who is
currently visiting the FBC or the
Federal Bureau of control the FBC
basically handles all manner of
paranatural phenomena and they have
different names to classify different
items altered items are weird objects
that aren't exactly dangerous but don't
act in a normal manner like this fridge
that hurts you if you don't look at it
continuously above that are objects of
power which are altered items that have
a connection to the astral plane like
the hotline a rotary foam with the dial
missing that only can be used by the
director of The Bureau as it allows them
to contact the dead as well as other
paranatural entities like the board the
highest of tiers belongs to awes or
altered world events these are events
that occur when paranatural forces
invade our world a good example of an
alter world event would be the three
times the dark presence has done battle
with bright Falls those fights against
Thomas Zayn the Anderson Brothers and
Alan Wake all count as aw's in fact the
bureau has numerous documents on the
event so they're aware of what occurred
during the game something consistent
amongst remedies games that they all
happen the year the game was released
alen wake for example takes place in
2010 the year the game was released
Allen wake 2 is supposedly going to be
13 years later which matches up with the
2023 release date by that metric control
then takes place in 2019 meaning it's
almost been 10 years since Allen left
breit Falls so it's no wonder that the
bureau has already caught on to the
incident in fact breit Falls is quite
unique as it's the only awe on record to
have occurred in the same place more
than once the DLC starts in typical
Allan Wake fashion where Allan writes
something in his typewriter which then
plays out a few moments later giving off
the impression that he's controlling the
events of the DLC like how he wrote the
events of the base game some have even
gone as far as to say that Allen
influenced the whole plot of control
regarding the FBC and the hiss while I
don't personally agree with that it does
seem to stem from the fact that Allan
knows a lot about the FBC and Jesse even
mentioning Polaris her paranatural
entity by name which is something only
Jesse knows this also goes back to the
discussion we had in American Nightmare
how does Allan know that Barry was
managing the Anderson Brothers if he's
been in the dark place the whole time I
don't recall the game ever mentioning
how Allan knows anything outside of the
confines of the dark place but let me
know if I'm wrong either way this DLC is
another attempt of Allen to write his
Escape through his writing he sets up a
conflict between Jesse and Dr Hartman
who's now turned into this monstrous
being since the incident at bright Falls
the FBC have cataloged numerous findings
interviews and experiments they managed
to find two altered items which were a
coffee thermos of reference to the
in-game collectible and a manuscript
page similar to that there was a
document in control that talks about the
bureau discovering that people have been
selling altered items on the black
market and Allan's manuscript Pages seem
to be a part of that list too they also
have a note mentioning that Dr Emil
Hartman and agent Nightingale are
currently missing however they were able
to find Dr Hartman later but placed him
on arrest for not only violating normal
laws but laws pertaining to the bureau
Hartman has then been at the bureau ever
since but he's definitely seen better
days furthermore through some other
notes we find out that FBI agent Alex
Casey was looking for information
regarding the brightfalls awe which yes
is as crazy as it sounds because that
means Alex Casey is no longer a
fictional character but a real person
now on top of this the first time we
meet Allan we can see him talking with
Thomas Zayn but as we know Thomas is
gone this has led to two theories which
are that this is the bright presid
presence who is just using a different
form to talk to Allen or that this is Mr
scratch pretending to be the diver that
Allen has conversed with as remember
Allen isn't really on speaking terms
with Thomas SL the bright presence as we
never see him outside of the diving suit
furthermore the bright presence Thomas
Zay Duo is voiced by James mcaffrey but
this Thomas Zayn is voiced by Michael
peretta the voice of Allan and Mr
scratch either way this person claiming
to be Thomas Zayn says that Mr scratch
is still out there confirming that he
didn't die at the end of American
nightmare but this person claims to be
handling it and Alice has actually
reached out to the bureau on her own to
talk about her problems as she's been
having nightly visions of Allan she
managed to catch a photo of him on
camera and it's a real charmer to cap
things off the end of the DLC sees Jesse
defeating Hartman by turning on the
lights which is a nice touch and then
peppering him with bullets once he's
defeated Langston a fairly important
member within control calls Jesse and
tells him that they have an alert about
another awe the confusing part is that
it's not only in bright falls again but
it's also said a few years in the future
now at the time this was likely teasing
something out Alan Wake related
fortunately we have the gift of
hindsight and we know that this is
specifically talking about alen wake 2
which will have us return to Bright
Falls once again this may not sound like
a ton of important information but this
was always designed to be a Side Story
as ultimately the DLC is a part of
control this is Jesse's story not
Allen's but it was nice to see Allan
make an appearance regardless what this
means for the future is uncertain but at
the very least Jesse is aware of Allen
and the awe coming to Bright Falls so
I'll be interested to see if she or
another agent arrives during the events
of the sequel
I've said it a million times before and
I'll say it a million more I love Alan
Wake it was a game I enjoyed years ago
when I was a teen and it's a game I
still enjoy today from its gameplay to
its story Alan Wake is a game enveloped
in originality and passion its concept
of using light against your enemy was
something I hadn't experienc at the time
and while the combat can still feel a
bit cheap at times it's something I
enjoyed regardless it story though is
easily a highlight of my experience and
is a testament to remedy's Talent this
recursive story about Allan desperately
trying to save his wife and battling the
horrors of unknown entities while
writing a story that he's about to
perform and act is mind-bending enough
to make your brain hurt but it's a story
that stuck on me for years and years and
with the release of the sequel it'll
likely stick around for a few more just
like Allan though I'm hoping that this
next game will be the last is why I
would like more games in this series I
want nothing more than to see him Escape
for now though both of us will have to
remain in limbo while we await the
release of the sequel but the hope that
this will be the last book Allen will
ever have to write again thanks for
watching thank you for watching today
and I hope you enjoyed it's been a
minute since we've had an hourlong
feature on the channel so glad to be
back the next video will obviously be on
Allan Wake 2 also I know I'm super late
to this but I don't think I ever
actually officially mentioned it in a
video but thank you for 300,000
subscribers it's a number I never
thought I could hit and I couldn't have
done it without you so thank you as
always like the video if you enjoy and
subscribe if you're new thank you to my
returning viewers are coming back to
another video and take care everyone
goodbye